fair enough thank you very much uh so hi
my name is aaron sidford i'm a grad
student at mit and currently a fellow
here for the semester
and i'll be talking about a faster
algorithm for linear programming
and the maximum flow problem part two so
everything we say in this talk is joint
work with the last speaker yin tai li
who's also a grad student at mit and a
fellow here
so i'm going to pick up this talk is
going to pick up more or less where
intense less stop left off
but don't worry if you missed the last
talk or had enough sugar
in between sessions that you forgot
everything i'll recap things as you need
them
as you need them so in the last talk
ginta talked about different algorithms
for linear programming
in particular interior point methods and
went over sort of how you could analyze
the convergence rate of interior point
schemes
how good these different interior point
schemes were in their convergence rate
and what um very very broadly what their
asymptotic running time was like were
they polynomial or did they require
solving linear programs as a subroutine
what i'm going to focus on in this talk
is how to really bring and he also
presented how to he also presented how
to get uh the first polynomial time
convergence into your point scheme that
matched uh sort of the best known
existential results we had for such
schemes
what i'm going to focus on in this talk
is how to make how to get the same sort
of convergence rate but keep the cost of
the iterations down
and when i say keep them down i mean
have them on the order of magnitude of
basically
the cheapest iteration interior point
methods that we have
so i'll say i'll motivate exactly what
that is why this is a good model for
solving linear programming and analyzing
running times
i'll show how we get a good running time
in that model
and i'll go over some of the
applications and actual running times
for linear programming with that
but just quick recap we're talking about
the same problem as the last talk
we're want to solve an arbitrary linear
program so we have some n variables x
some cost vector c
we want to minimize the inner product of
x and c and we want to do this subject
to m linear inequality constraints that
are given by some matrix a
and some vector b again this this is
just the dual of a linear program in
standard form
it's well known you can write all linear
programs like this and just
again to make sure everyone's refreshed
after all the sugar the picture for this
um
we think of every inequality constraint
to find some half space in rn
our fusible region is the intersection
of these n half spaces
um and our goal is to minimize if
you took this intersection on the plane
you get some convicts polygon and higher
dimensions we call it a polytope
and our goal is to minimize a linear
function over this feasible region
whenever i draw these for the rest of
the talk i'll always have the cost
function pointed straight up
so our goal for the rest of the talk is
to find the bottom of this high
dimensional convex body
um so as we saw in let's talk there are
many methods for doing this there's the
simplex where you basically walk around
the boundary of the polytube working
towards the bottom
there's the ellipsoid method where you
start with some large convex body that
contains the entire polytope
you keep shrinking it so you contain
nothing but the optimal point
and there's interior point methods which
as the name suggests and we saw on the
last talk
you start with some point in the
interior of the polytope and you
iteratively move it towards the bottom
now um in across a broad range of
parameters the fastest algorithms we
have are all interior point methods
these are the type of methods that
intel was talking about in this last
talk and these the type of methods i'll
focus on in this talk
and again interior point methods you
shouldn't think that they're
one optimization algorithm there isn't
like the interior point algorithm
rather like many iterative methods for
convex optimization they refer to a
broad
class of optimization algorithms that
essentially turn
one difficult optimization problem into
a much to a
sequence of much simpler optimization
problems we can solve
in the last talk inside focused on how
many problems do we have to solve
in order to get to solve the linear
program what i'm going to talk much more
about in this talk is how hard are these
sub-problems and how do i really keep
the cost
of those sub-problems down so in this
lens let's look at the previous
uh look at the previous running times so
here i'm using
listing uh the previous uh interior
point
algorithms i'm listed gonna list the
iteration count
here i am writing down how many
iterations you need to get one more bit
of precision in your algorithm
so if you're familiar with the usual l
term you keep around an interior point
analysis i'm just dropping that term
uh and i'm the on the right hand side
here is the cost of the actual
iterations
so the first proof of the interior point
method converging in polynomial time
was due to car and you really need to
solve
and linear systems i'll get to it in a
sec no no i should it should be
quotes there there should be a quotes
there that are fast matrix
multiplication but i'll say
i'll say in a sec right so this is like
rough order magnitude of the cost of the
iterations i'll say i'll go over now
what
exactly the cost of these previous the
iterations of these previous methods are
so first there was the first proof of an
interior point method converging in
polynomial time
was due to karmakar in 1984 given o of m
iteration algorithm where the cost of
every iteration was on the order
magnitude of solving a linear system
this was improved by renegar in 1986 who
got a squared m
iteration algorithm where the cost is
roughly the same running time
and here when i say solve a linear
system i don't mean some arbitrary
massive linear system
i mean basically the computational
bottleneck in every iteration of these
algorithms
was doing a projection onto the image of
some rescaling of a
or if you prefer to think about
regression problems you think we just
had some diagonal scaling matrix d
and we wanted to solve a regression
problem in d a and that was the
computational bottleneck in every
iteration
however the number of constraints in
general can be much much larger than the
number of variables
so there are these breakthrough results
of vaidya showing that you can get
faster
convergence rate you can get convergence
rates that depend better on the number
of variables rather than the number of
constraints
if you don't mind spending a bit more
per year iterations
so here i wrote solving n or m linear
systems
really the computational bottleneck was
something like either computing a
projection matrix or it's diagonal
if you do all the right optimizations
for
you should think of them you can think
of the complexity of them as the
complexity of computing the diagonal of
a projection matrix involving a
or basically exactly computing the
leverage scores of every row of a
under some sort of re-weighting so you
could do this by solving m linear
systems or solving n linear systems
you could also do this by fast matrix
multiplication
but in general for an arbitrary linear
system this could be much slower than
this
for instance we know how to solve linear
systems and input sparsity time
something that depends on nnz of a plus
some poly and d
we do not know how to compute leverage
scores like a log one over epsilon
convergence in the same running time
nor do we know how to explicitly form
this diag this in this
either this matrix or is inverse in the
same running time anything input
sparsity
which is more of the bottleneck of this
routine so in essence they need sort of
more information about the polytope
exactly
and slows down their convergence rate
this was in further improved by the
conversion rate was further improved by
nestor avenovsky
uh in 1994. this was the universal
barrier yinta
talked about in the last talk but as we
saw in general
the current time of comp using this to
get iterations of an interior point
scheme
the sub problem you have to solve is
harder than linear programming itself
so until recently it looked like you can
get algorithms that run
in less and less iterations they have
iterations that depend better and better
on the intrinsic dimension of the
problem n
if and only if you're willing to spend
much more work for your iteration
so in the last talking that showed how
you could keep the iteration complexity
you can get it polynomial
here what we show is you can actually up
to poly logarithmic factors
match the convergence rate of the
universal barrier and have the
complexity of the iterations be on the
same order of magnitude of renegar's
algorithm
so every iteration of our scheme will
just solve some polylog number of linear
systems
and they'll be linear systems of the
same form just doing
solving some regression problem for some
rescaling of a
and why would you want to do this well
first just note that the fastest
algorithms we actually have
in theory and practice for a large set
of parameter regimes
are instances of renegar's algorithm
they basically come by
in theory many of our results say let's
run redengar's algorithm let's look at
the linear systems we have to solve
and we'll use the best algorithms we
know for solving these linear systems or
use some information about how the
structure of these linear systems change
between iterations
in practice also the fastest algorithms
we have often come from taking renegar's
algorithm
but not rather than running it with the
analysis that gives you square root n
trying to take much more aggressive
steps
think rather than pushing the constraint
and yintat's picture by a little bit you
push it by as much as you can and hope
for the best
so one of the reasons we'd want to
reduce to solving these linear systems
is so
in theory we could capitalize on a lot
of the benefits that come
we could capitalize on a lot of the
benefits that have been come from using
linear systems like in renegar's
algorithm
and in practice it says we're still sort
of running in the same general framework
we're just getting a better convergence
rate
but still if you've never seen all of
this it may look a little it look a
little weird if you haven't gone through
many interior point schemes or look at
very different linear programs you might
really be asking is this really a good
model should we really be measuring the
complexity of solving a linear program
in terms of the number of linear systems
you've had to solve
and you also might be asking and even if
you have seen this you might be asking
is this the end of the story
is basically the best we can hope for is
bound the number of linear systems we
have to solve and try to just match the
universal barrier or standard
self-concordance analysis of barriers
and not try to do any more than that so
to answer both of these questions we'll
go
to the main theme of this workshop and
the program for this semester and we'll
consider the maximum flow problem
and i'll try to use this to address uh
both these questions
so i'm sure everyone knows this but i i
feel bad just saying the problem without
a definition so we want to solve the
maximum flow problem we have some
directed graph g
vertices v and edges e we have some
non-negative capacities mu
we have two special vertices s and t as
an end
as i'm sure all of you know our goal is
to send as much stuff from s to t as
possible
without exceeding the capacity
constraints
so what's the best running time for
solving this problem oh before i say
that let's
first do the mapping for how we should
how we're going to think about this as a
linear program
so i could just i'll just add some edge
from t to s
i'll now make my objective function
rather than sending as much stuff from s
to t
i'll just say put as much stuff on the
ts edge as possible
my variables i'll just have will be some
vector in rm just an assignment of value
to the edges
i'll now restrict uh to the space of
circulation the space of the
i'll add the linear constraints that
flow in equals flow out for every single
vertex
and i'll add the inequality constraints
that my flow is
larger larger than zero and less than
the capacity
um all right so how fast can we solve
this problem well
culminating a long line of beautiful
work on combinatorial algorithms for
this problem there's this result of
goldberg and row
1980 that you can solve it in the
smaller of number of edges of the graph
to the three halves
or number of edges times number of
vertices to the two thirds
all right now how does this compare to
if we just try to use linear programming
to solve the problem how does it compare
to these interior point schemes
well if we just apply renegar's result
to this linear program it's pretty
immediate to show you can solve it and
square root number of edges in the
iteration number of edges iterations
and moreover if you look at these linear
systems you have to solve you're solving
some regression problem and this is just
the incidence matrix of a graph
so the computational complex so the
bottleneck in every iteration of
renegar's algorithm is solving some
laplacian system
so we can use this beautiful white very
powerful result of spielman tang in 2004
that we can solve every one of these
systems in nearly linear time
so if you just put these two things
together as deutschen spielman did in
2008
on the paper that achieved some other
cool results along the way it shows that
at least
for the case of sparse graphs just
standard interior point analysis
with the right linear system solver in
every iteration gives you an algorithm
that matches the asymptotic running time
of goldberg rao
at least in the regime of sparse graphs
up to poly logarithmic factors
also very excitingly as we heard earlier
in the week
alexander madre just very recently
showed there's a modification of an
interior point scheme
that you can do use in the case of unit
capacity graphs
to get an algorithm whose running time
is number of edges to the 10-7 so it's
faster for in the case of sparse graphs
and what i'll discuss a bit in this talk
is we show that there's a modification
of our interior point scheme that we can
you apply to this linear program
that will get a similar square number of
edges to square a number of vertices
improvement
so we'll show that we can get an
interior point scheme that converges in
square number of vertices iterations
we'll still be solving a polylog number
of similar linear systems in every
iteration
and we'll get the answer and number of
edges times square number of vertices
which will be faster in the case of
dense graphs
i want to note here that we won't get
this by doing some special
combinatorial algorithm for maximum flow
or doing much combinatorial analysis for
maximum flow
rather we're just going to show for this
slightly broader class of linear
programs
if i take the dual of my linear program
in standard form but add two-sided
inequality constraints
rather than the typical one-sided y is
bigger than zero
so if this was just y bigger than zero
this would be standard form i'll add the
two-sided constraints
we'll show that this linear program even
though there's m variables and m
inequality constraints and the only
thing that's n is the number of linear
inequality constraints
even though this problem neither this
problem nor its dual is n-dimensional
nevertheless you can still solve this in
square root number of vertices
iterations
but because we'll get it and then those
iterations linear systems you solve will
just be laplacian systems so we'll get
the running time
but since we get this just by showing
you can solve this problem problem in
general
whether c is uh just simply putting one
unit on s to t or an arbitrary cost
function doesn't really make any
difference in our analysis
as long as the numbers aren't too big so
we'll get the same running time for
solving minimum cost flow for free
or moreover solving basically everything
that dejan spielman showed how to
show it how to solve in their paper in
2008 the other thing i want to note
about this is this isn't a direct
corollary of the previous result
moreover if you try to just use the
universal barrier to solve this linear
program you would not get a
well and apply the standard analysis you
would not get a square root number of
vertices convergent algorithm
moreover you can show that if you try to
make a barrier for this domain
there doesn't exist a barrier whose
self-concordance is m
so in some sense this algorithm is
converging at a rate that's better than
the standard theory of interior point
so which i take as at least exciting
times that between this and manju's
results suggest that
some of the classical reasons we
thinking we had for thinking what
exactly are the limits of interior point
schemes
don't always hold at least in certain
broad classes of linear programs
we can have things that still look like
interior point yet outperform the
standard analysis of interior point
schemes
um all right so that's about all i'm
going to say for maximum flow so
probably the end of the talk
the rest of it i'm going to try to give
basically a proof by picture of our
algorithm i'll really briefly
review where yinta left us off in terms
of getting fast convergence rates for
interior point schemes
i'll say why and then i'll walk through
a sequence of why we might hope for a
faster running time or what the
bottleneck is to a faster running time
and how we get through the technical
barriers to keep bringing the
running time of iterations each
iteration down and then as i have time
for the end i'll talk about some
applications and extensions so i'll
discuss a little bit what had to change
to get the same convergence rate for the
maximum flow
problem and i'll go over what the
running time is if we use different
types of linear system solvers or we use
some of these tricks that are typically
used to get faster convergence rates out
of renegar's algorithm
so that's the plan any questions before
i dive into our scheme
so you made comments that that the
entire
top don't immediately go to the square
root of any duration
uh not for this not for this linear
program
no not immediately
so
i mean there's i mean the reason you say
there isn't a self-concordant barrier
for the domain is just there really can
be m
tight constraints and you can show if
that really happens at optimality then
the local region
around that vertex um you can find a
point such that there might that
that it couldn't be self-concording like
you can find a counter a contradiction
to itself concordance around
that vertex the main type constraints
yeah um there could be some other linear
program that projects down to this that
you could work in that space and do it
but we're not
aware of such a thing uh instead what
we'll do is derive a
scheme that just works directly in this
space and still gets the square root n
i'll talk a little bit more at the very
end about how we do that
um any other questions
all right so quick recap let's go back
to interior
point schemes and what they are and what
where we got to with barriers and
everything and we'll talk about what the
bottleneck was
and how we're going to get around that
bottleneck so again
we have this polytope we want to
minimize the linear function over it
we assume we have some barrier p which
is just some function such that the
value of p
blows up some function p on the interior
of the polytope
such that the value of p goes to
infinity as i bring my point towards the
boundary of the polytope
and our scheme will be the following
rather than trying to minimize the cost
function we'll just add a constraint
that our cost is less than some value
we'll do we'll assume that we have some
transformation so that at least
initially we can get some trivial
initial point that minimizes the barrier
for this polytope that consists of
polytope plus cost constraint
again typically there is some generic
transformation you can use to do this
that doesn't blow up your overall
running time
and once we have this initial point what
we'll do is we'll move our cost
constraint
moving our cost constraint will
correspond to updating our barrier
typically i should note in both analysis
and our paper and many of the analysis
this cost constraint is treated as
something soft
it's treated as a soft penalty rather
than this hard one but the picture and
the geometry is a bit nicer if i do this
and the so i'll keep doing it this way
and then i'll compute a new center so
i've moved the cost constraint this has
changed my penalty function i need to
find this new initial point
and the way we'll find the center is the
way interior point methods typically
find this center we'll just run some
number of iterations of newton's method
so in here in case not very familiar
newton's method i simply mean we'll take
our penalty function our barrier
function p
we'll look at the second order taylor
approximation of the function
this will be some linear term and some
quadratic terms some matrix
and we'll minimize that that'll be our
next point maybe
maybe we don't step all the way we might
damp down the step a little bit
but we'll step in that direction and
repeat this some number of times
until we're extremely close to the
center and we'll repeat
and that'll be the whole algorithm but
you can imagine what this algorithm is
doing
is if i imagine taking the cost
constraint and really slowly moving it
down and looking at the update the
barrier and looking at the
corresponding center the corresponding
center
what this will do is it'll track out
some smooth curve through the interior
of the polytope
this is called the central path
and our algorithm of taking these newton
steps to find the new center
you can think of as some of moving the
cost constraint and finding the new
center
is then some sort of discretization of
the central path
so how will our algorithm do we'll do
we'll have to do with how well we can
descritize this path
right so how well does our algorithm
discretize the path we already saw this
in the last talk
let's instantiate in the case of
renegar's algorithm since that's the
algorithm we're probably we're going to
be trying to compete with in terms of
iteration complexity
so renegar's algorithm more or less
followed the same scheme
the barrier that was used in that
algorithm is was the log barrier
one of the standard barriers used in
many regimes and this barrier i simply
look at every constraint
i look at my difference to that
constraint i take 1 over my distance to
that constraint i take a log of it and i
sum that up for every single constraint
and that's the log barrier the center
for the log barrier has a special name
is called the analytic center of the
polytope
and if we want to know how well our
interior point scheme does
how easy is it how much can i move the
cost constraint such that i can easily
find
the new center well our algorithm is
just minimizing the second order taylor
approximation to the function
so i'll have to do with how fast that
second order approximation changes
so if i simply draw this so if i take my
previous center
and i draw the second order the contour
the equi-cost contour of the
second-order taylor approximation to the
point
this is just some ellipse given by the
second-order term called the hessian
if i scale it appropriately this has a
name it's called the deacon ellipse
as united said in his talk and he said
the way
and the way we we're going to think
about how fast our algorithm converges
is how good this deakin ellipse is as an
approximation to the polytope
so we'll call it an m rounding if i
scale it up by a factor of m
it contains the entire polytope and as
since i've discussed in the last talk
it's well known that for the log barrier
the deacon ellipse and the worst can be
an m rounding of the polytope but it's
at most an m rounding of the polytope
and as students had explained this
yields a squared m iteration algorithm
um there's a again there's smoothness
and stability probably properties that
are needed as well that i don't have
quite as nice a picture for
so we'll just think of this as net for
now as the property we need
the true property again is
self-concordance but this should be
enough to convey the intuition i want to
convey a better algorithm
all right so to do better as instead
point out we know that there are
ellipsoids that are better roundings of
the polytope we can use this result of
context geometry of fritz john that if i
compute the ellipse of maximum volume
contained inside the polytope
if i scale that up by a factor of n it
contains the entire polytope
so we derived it another way before but
this is just a barrier of maybe trying
to consider the volume of the maximum
inscribed ellipse centered at a point
however we've discussed this barrier is
bad it's non-smooth it's sort of
unstable it would also be difficult
compute
so we don't use that instead we use this
regularized john ellipse barrier
so something for maximizing the volume
of the deacon ellipse with some
regularization terms
and this is what as the intent said in
this talk this gives an end rounding of
an almost end an end rounding of the
polytope up to poly logarithmic factors
which in turn yields a squared end
iteration algorithm
i'm just saying here i'm just writing
what the regularization terms are they
make sure that the weights are spread
out somewhat uniformly
so that uh if we have a bunch of
redundant constraints we have a very
principled way to break
ties between them which makes these
weight variables more stable
and we also add some term to not let any
of the weights get too small
so that's our volume so that's it this
this works this gives us an n rounding
and a squared iteration algorithm
so why are we not done why are there 90
pages on archive and why am i still
giving this talk
surely there wasn't like that much
calculus to just make this whole thing
work
and the answer is we alluded to in the
last talk is that actually computing
this barrier
both doing this maximization problems
over the weights
or minimizing x even if we had the
weights is expensive
basically computing the gradient is
expensive it's more expensive than
solving a linear system
so before i say i get around it maybe we
should ask should we really hope for
cheater
cheaper iterations it does make sense
that there's something sort of
multi-dimensional we really have to
compute about some notion of importance
of all the different constraints
and maybe this really intrinsically
takes a lot of time to compute to get
information that precise that we can use
to really get a good rounding
so again the centering problem is this
minim
so you can think when we take that
barrier from the last talk
if we actually compute the center we're
solving this mini max problem
our barrier was the maximization over w
and we're minimizing over x to find the
center
so if i want to compute the gradients of
this either with respect to
x or with respect to w or equivalently
if i want to certify them either w
or x is actually optimal for this
barrier i i need to compute something
like leverage scores
if you just write out the gradient for
what the gradient is for this you'll get
something involving the leverage scores
of the matrix
or in the graph case something that
basically corresponds to the effective
resistance of every edge in the graph
and this makes sense we're trying to
make this thing be a maximum volume it
makes sense you need some measure of
everything's impo
contribution to the volume and this is a
natural motion
all right so are we really done naively
if we wanted to compute every single
leverage score or effective resistance
naively this would take m linear system
solves or do dense matrix multiplication
but as we've seen in many other talks in
this workshop
and many other things in this program we
know how to compute these things
approximately very efficiently
so we can use this clever trick of
seamless roster in 2008
that what i um what we're computing here
is diag the diagonal entries of some
projection matrix
so if i want the diagonal measure we
have a projection matrix since
the projection matrix times itself is
itself
some diagonal entry is the same thing as
just the l2 norm of a row or a column
so what i can do is i could just project
the entire matrix onto some low
dimensional space
i could just pick some jl transformation
uh
so then getting everything's leverage
score i could just get
from its norm in this lower dimensional
space
so basically i could just pick a jl
matrix multiply from the left
and i can get every leverage score
approximately up to poly epsilon
while only solving a polylog number of
linear systems all i needed to do was
multiply
a polylog number of vectors from the
left so this was just solving some
polylog number of linear systems
all right so this is good this says we
can get these leverage scores
approximately so at least we can get
access to this information that would
certify that we're close to having this
maximum volume ellipse that you want
this seems like we're on the right track
but for anyone that's
done a bunch of analysis of interior
point methods or tried to prove they
work this should be extremely dubious
what i just said
in general interior point methods or
newton's method doesn't tolerate that
kind of error
in your gradient it's not good enough
just to have multiplicative
approximation if you have only have
multiplicative approximations to every
coordinate of the gradient
some sense you maybe shouldn't hope for
getting something much more than a
multiplicative approximation to the
point you're trying to go for
without spending a many many logs many
many without having many many iterations
like you won't get a log one over
epsilon type convergence
and this is problematic because if we
want to actually do our interior points
scheme and get that square root
we really need to be very close to the
center or some sort of center if we're
going to try to get that square root of
the volume
so we need to find some way to get very
close to the center and getting just
this approximate notion of the leverage
scores wouldn't be enough
moreover really the gradient is the
matrix applied to leverage score so
things would get distorted even more
so we need some way to get a more
precise estimate of the gradient so we
can really center well with respect to
something
um and again you so you know just
there might be this money just it might
sound a little confusing because it is
true that multiplicative approximations
to the hessian are just fine
if i want to run newton's method i only
need to get some spectral approximation
to the second order term that i don't
need to know too well
but if i really want to minimize it
precisely like get some sort of linear
convergence
in general i don't know how to do that
without having the gradient pretty
precisely
i mean since you're driving the
the norm to zero multiplicative
approximation
pretty okay because you're multiplying
by zero
or something uh yeah so if it's exactly
at
well the other big problem here is
you're applying
you're taking these approximate leverage
scores and applying the matrix a to them
which will distort everything even
even more so yeah you could you could
maybe hope to certify if something's
not there at all but then if you're
trying to really get closer it would
be a three way yeah but it's the a
that's causing the problem
that's causing your first intuition
about a derivative
i mean if you could derive it to zero a
multiplicative approximation
isn't there also but if uh if i'm going
to do it in newton's method i'm then
going to transform everything with some
hessian also
so there can maybe be i could think of
ways pretty easily get like poly
epsilons but to get the log one over
absolute convergence out of it
most of my intuition is definitely for
this problem in specific
i haven't thought try to make that into
rigorous uh
okay wait so don't you also have a
problem where you're defining this as
this min and max
process like sort of at each step of
like verifying
a minimax thing or something you need to
compute leverage scores and if those
leverage scores are approximate
it also could make your solution even if
those levels are multiplicative
approximations that's no guarantee that
your solution will be anything like a
multiplicative approximation either
right yeah
so that's another issue we'd have to
devise a scheme for that and i'd be
a little worried about trying to get
really really close but moreover we
don't even have
exactly a multiplier approximation to
the gradient the power expansions aren't
good i just i'm trying to
figure out all these yeah so yeah if you
wanted to be even more scary you're
applying some matrix to it also so
um that might not be in a space such
that you can easily reason about how
that gets distorted
uh anything else is that also what we
said
is that yeah i think you were saying
similar wasn't in the beginning if
you're doing this
if you're iteratively approximating the
man of that or something
um and using leverage scores at each
step and those leverage quotes each step
are approximate
because this is not a very stable
authorization problem it's only stable
like square roots or something
yeah well you'd have to prove i uh
drastically off even if you had
pretty good approximate leverage squares
each step yeah so you'd have to
i guess it depends on the stability in
some set in some sense
uh i have to hedge to be very a little
careful response because at some point
we will do exactly this
we will compute some gradient
multiplicatively
and show that's okay to get my point
multiplicatively but this will come from
uh not behind another like working in a
space where multiplicative errors are
okay
and so but that requires proof it
requires some stability of the actual
thing you're solving so we will do
something like that
and yeah it doesn't hold here as far as
i know now but
if it did it would be cool it would
simplify a lot of things
all right anything else
all right so what are we going to do
about this so let's
go back to the drawing board let's go
back to the thing that we know we
compute the gradient
of let's go back to like our benchmark
for efficient iterations let's look at
the log barrier
and try to see if we can take or take
our intuition about what just happened
to construct a way to manipulate the log
barrier to have it have the right
properties
so this is our thing that has cheap
iterations and let's think again like
what was really wrong with the log
barrier why does it depend on m versus n
and as the intent alluded to the problem
is really that the log barrier isn't
invariant in any sense under the
representation of the polytope
basically in the choice of how to give
the polytope i could repeat a constraint
a number of times
that would repeat some log barrier term
this would really then
increase the force of the barrier in
some direction and it's not too hard to
see this would really perturb the
central path
so in some sense the adversary and their
choice of how to give us the linear
program
has this freedom to effectively reweight
our constraints
where these weights are controlled
controlled by the adversary
so in essence we maybe want to work with
some good
uh log barrier that's right for our
problem but all we're stuck with if we
don't do anything is the log barrier
that's given by some adversary
that wanted to make our path as curvy
and hard to descritize as possible
but this is just naturally what you
should do if the problem is the
adversary is the freedom of this
parameter to mess you up you should
optimize over that freedom to try to
undo the adversary
um so we can push that so we could try
to push back to the other path
so we're going to try to do is work in
this space of weights to make it so that
our weighted log barrier
always locally has the right properties
that we can still get this end
convergence rate
we'll use the this result of the other
barrier sort of an existence result that
there is some nice object
and try to push in a way that we can
still access it from this space
where we can at least optimize something
precisely so to be a little more
specific you can think every here
here every single weight induces some
different central path through the
polytope
i could have run my algorithm with some
different choice of weights this would
be some
different some some different path and
for every one of these pads
for every choice of weights i really can
minimize this approximately i still have
cheap iterations for the weighted log
barrier
the problem is with the wrong choice of
rates it might not represent the space
locally the right way
so we'll try to take all the intuition
about how we can make good barriers
before
to find a way to iteratively and
maintain the invariant that we always
have good weights
this thing we call pathfinding because
we're always going to be trying to find
a better path or switch the central path
we're on
but right here i want to note that this
is not like
necessarily our idea it's an old idea
that's been around for a while even some
of the original papers of vaidya's had
references to log
to weighted log barrier it's occurred in
other places in the interior point
literature
and i should also point out that that
madre's paper getting faster max flow
is also picking weights on the central
path
however as far as i know these early
these are the results that were weighed
in the central path they never got an
improved
convergence rate like this and
alexander's and madrid's algorithm for
perturbing the weights it when every
time if you're at some point here
and you change the ways to go to some
path you'll no longer be on the central
path and you'll have to get there and it
might be expensive to get there
or if you really move it it might be
difficult to reason about what happens
of how how much you maintain the
invariance so much paper
couples this many of the modifications
to the weights to actual perturbations
of the polytope
to make it easier to argue what's going
on so
this poses some challenges to not do
that so we're going to try to
have a sequence of changes in weights so
we can maintain the invariance that we
want namely that our deacon ellipse is a
good rounding of the polytope
and we're going to try to do that while
still being able to center with respect
to something
but why should this work why should our
intuition about this other barrier that
work harry over to here
but well the answer was in the last talk
uh so the john ellipse if i look at the
ellipse of maximum volume
in fact it's not too hard to show that
is for a polytope elise it's always
realizable as the deacon ellipse of the
dot log barrier
what i mean by this is for any polytope
there exists a choice of weights
such that if i computed the center with
respect to those weights
its deakin ellipse is precisely the is
precisely the john ellipse
um moreover one thing that's nice about
this is you can show if you only have
these weights multiplicatively
up to some constant this will only
perturb the quality of your rounding up
to some constant
so what this suggests is what we can do
is we can always make sure we're exactly
minimizing some weights
where we just don't change the weights
too much that we can always completely
center with respect to a certain type of
weights
and all we need is that our weights to
be close enough to something that would
give us a good rounding of the polytope
and then we could hope to get a fast
convergence rate
but we look at it mathematically i'm
maybe not really saying something crazy
that saying something that deep before
we were saying we'll minimize the
uh minimize x while maximizing over w
computing the gradients that were hard
instead we're saying we'll do this path
finding thing
we'll just note that for the right
choice of weights
the log barrier locally looks like what
it should have looked like with x and
separately we'll try to get our weights
to come from some optimization problem
so what we'll do is we'll say if i could
compute
an x and w so that x is centered with
respect to those weights and weight has
this problem the weights have this
property
then locally they're not exactly the
same thing but they'll look similar
enough i can still get a good rounding
and again the win of this is here the
gradients of everything involves
computing leverage scores but here
the gradient with respect to x i only
need to know my weights exactly
so i can compute the gradient in linear
time it's just applying a
to the slacks into the weights the
hessian requires
a bit more work i'm not going to form
but i know it explicitly so i can still
solve regression problems in it
and i still need to know the leverage
scores to get
the weights but i only need them
approximately if i want rounding
properties
so this is our hope for a win and this
is what our algorithm more or less does
so we use this weighted log barrier and
the idea is we're going to
take newton's steps on x and w so i can
also
um if i change weights it's also on this
it's all so easy if i change my weights
here it's also easy
to argue about how much closer i get to
the central of some path
so here for the argument for x
you can do everything exactly so if like
uh newton's method still works well if
i'm close enough to the central path
i can get very very close extremely
while only solving a few linear systems
like if i'm in the convergence ball then
exactly and that's
important yeah we're here exactly i mean
linear convergence like i mean a log one
over epsilon type dependence
yeah and then the second one that's
where you're allowed to
approximate yeah we don't we don't need
the optimal weights
if we locally want to make a bunch of
progress we just need to have this
rounding and some stability property
that we can certify locally
now this might be tricky because when i
take steps i might like take
some step using my current set of
weights and find that the optimal
weights i want
for a john ellipse have drifted off
somewhere else so
it's going to take a bit of work to
prove that that doesn't happen that i
can simultaneously make those invariants
but we're saying if we do my weights
don't really have to exactly be anything
they just need to not be too far
multiplicatively from something that
gives me a good rounding
that's what that approximately equals
just that if you take the actual r
max each weight is within a
multiplicative factor
yeah so we're going to make we're going
to maintain the variant that our weights
are multiplicative within a
multiplicative factor of something we
knew would give us a good rounding
okay is the game clear
all right so this is the actual
algorithm so it's also one
the thing i said at the very end was
just also i can try to
make x closer to being centered to some
weights by changing weights like i can
compute certain gradients on weights and
that's easy also
basically the log barrier i understand
getting close to some fixed central path
is fine
it's just getting the optimal central
path that's sort of hard
like it's not good to find it's not so
hard to find a decent path it's just
hard to find the best path
um so here's the algorithm so we start
with some set of weights
we'll computer center for those weights
we'll still move the cost constraint
and now we'll try to compute a new
center and to do this we'll take
something like a newton step on x and w
so we'll use that we know everything
about the weighted lock barrier to make
some movement on x and w so that we get
closer to some weighted central path and
then we'll assume is we have some advice
of like
uh the ideal weights you would have for
a given x
so assuming we have some advice about
what we would want the weights
to be locally so i would have the
rounding property if my x was central
centered and i'll move we'll move our
weights towards those
those weights and we'll repeat the idea
is here we want to move closer to some
weighted central path
and here we want to make sure that we
have a good rounding
and what we'll try to show is that i can
always move closer to the central path
then this fixing of the rounding will
bring me farther away
and what weight function do we pick what
we already said it's just going to be
from that maximization problem
so it's that same maximization problem
we were using as the barrier but we're
using it with
log barrier now
and this works you can show that this
will give a hessian as a rounding
and if you could compute this weight
exactly
then you would actually be pretty simple
you could just take a really small
newton step on x
you could set your weights to be the
optimal weights and you'd be done but
we're not
again we can't compute these weights
approximately so we have to do something
w or r of x on the right hand side uh
i think in the previous slide it should
have been r of w everywhere
i'm sorry yeah it should have been w
everywhere
the regularizer was always on w okay
yeah
i apologize so because otherwise it
wouldn't affect the optimization problem
yeah it would be yeah it would be silly
what is your so you have x and you
compute the weight function exactly you
say then in that case it's easy because
what why why even if you can compute it
exactly the move to the weight function
doesn't
put you far away and then you can you
can prove it
so yeah it requires proof actually
let me do the next slide and then i'll
answer a bunch i think there'll be more
questions to ask after the next slide
that are all related anyway all right
because and basically because i think
what i said just sounds like magic i
just said sort of you can treat them as
separate and everything's easier and
that's not
quite true the analysis gets quite
tricky like proving
that this weight that this weight
modification doesn't hurt you
is very very tricky uh it becomes a bit
harder to show
that the weights are stable in some
sense and the other thing is again we
never are actually going to compute
these weights we're only going to
compute them approximately and i haven't
said anything about how hard it is to
compute these weights
so i'm not going to talk about it here
but you can show if i give me a
multiplicative approximation to the
weights
i can get a better multiplicative
approximation in the weights without
solving too many linear systems
so we'll argue when we change our x the
weights we want don't shift too much
they're not too hard to compute
but the reason we have this here
this is what we call the split step in
our paper the reason we do both of these
is that if i just move my x a little my
weight might move a lot
um and my
what we we're not what might happen is
since we never really know our weights
exactly
whenever i move my weights towards the
true weights
they might be a totally wrong direction
sometimes
like all i'm really going to hope for is
on average i don't let my weights drift
too far away than the
true weights so the way we're going to
want to do this is that we're going to
say
there's this fixed amount that this
improves my centrality this like my
closeness is some central path
and i want to say no matter where i move
these weights
they won't hurt my centrality more than
this helped
so because i want to allow for just like
arbitrary basically multiplicative error
in this step because in some iterations
i might not get something more precise
so we try to extract from where we know
the weights will move
as much into a step that we can compute
exactly so that we can really pinpoint
the part we don't know so we can just
argue that that doesn't drift too much
and that requires proof that's that's
not easy requires a lot of
analysis of the weight function you need
to make it
without it yeah right yeah so
somehow the the centrality improvement
yeah
changes these x's and now you have these
new ways yep
just you know magic thinking right
and then somehow those new weights don't
going all the way to them doesn't
decrease your yeah so it requires proof
and it's careful
we split it we split it up like this so
that when
like the way we we prove that a small
step is good is we say
well if i did this step from that new
this will improve my centrality by so
much
and then from that new point how far
away the optimal weights i want aren't
that far
so i can afford to pay that error and
you could just instead just take the
small step and put all that in the proof
we actually explicitly
here are separated out into two parts so
that
i'm only going to pay multiplicative and
error in a space i know i can handle it
yeah how is this actually different from
just approximating the gradient of the
barrier by the gradient of the
corresponding weighted barrier weighted
log barrier
like is it like off the top of my head
i'm not sure
applying a to the leverage scores does
things that i'm scared to reason about
online the exact weights
into the weighted log barrier took the
grading it would not be the same as even
uh maybe the short i think i can do this
really quick note
this the fixed point of this is not the
same fixed point of this
okay right so they're not
that's that far off like it's just a
difference of certain regularization
terms but we are not
like in the ideal case we're not even
going to the same point
okay and this actually changed like this
actually makes your
answer um like this actually makes it
more stable or something using the
using your weighted button it's not just
in this space where we say these are the
parts i can compute exactly
so i don't know but yeah we're trying to
make get stability in the space of the
things we know computationally we can
get efficiently
like we're trying to map everything as
much as we can into the weighted log
barrier space where we know everything
exactly
so we can really pinpoint where our
error in the leverage scores will mess
us up
yeah um all right
this clear enough
all right so uh okay but i still we're
still not totally done
so all we've said is we know that well
if we do these steps we just know our
true weights don't drift too much
but we only get but that pla that space
in which they don't drift too much is
some small ball
relative to the l infinity ball in which
the weights can move
so we need to show that we can still
always maintain that our weights are
close to this optimal weights we want
but this we can just phrases some
self-contained game we can solve so
basically our setup is
every iteration of our algorithm we move
x and w
our optimal weights move in some
symmetric convex set s
some small ball we get some
multiplicative approximation to the
optimal weights which is potentially
some much bigger space
we're allowed to move our weights in any
set
that's just a little larger than that
convex set
but we're going to repeat this game
forever and what we want to ensure
is that our weight at all times
throughout this game is multiplicatively
close to the optimal weights
because if we can maintain that we'll
always have a good rounding and every
step will always make a lot of progress
so we call this the chasing zero game we
show you can play this game with a log
dependence on the size of s
it's um all you need to be able to do is
project onto s so just make people
minimize linears over
over that convex body s and it's
basically looks like some variant of
multiplicative widths
um it wasn't necessarily hard but it's a
little funny this s that we have is like
the intersection of an axis aligned ball
well then actually is a line box so
technically you had to prove that you
can do that in nearly linear time but it
just boils down to sorting
if you want a parallel algorithm you
technically have to prove you can do
that in parallel
but it's still just clever sorting in
parallel but that whole thing works
and that's the last piece i'm going to
go over so i'm going to try to recap
everything
so you can at least have one slide you
can get the picture of the algorithm
so going all the way back to the
beginning even the beginning of yintat's
talk our setup is the following
we want we're going to run this interior
point scheme and we need the deacon
ellipse to be a good rounding of our
polytope
we want to beat the standard m that
comes from renegar's algorithm
so what we can do is you can note that
the john ellipsoid gives you an n
rounding of the polytope
unfortunately using any doing anything
and following the john ellipse is all
conditioned
so we consider some sort of regularized
journalist barrier and after a bit of
a little non-standard analysis and from
munitions talk you can get a squared n
iteration algorithm
but now you want to make the iterations
more efficient so you know that
computing the gradient of this is
is expensive but fortunately johnson
linden strauss gives us a good
multiplicative approximation to parts of
the gradient
unfortunately newton's method can
actually handle the type of
approximation we can get
so instead we work in this different
space of path findings will
modify the weights to always maintain
that we have a good barrier
but when we do do this we need to show
that we can still always track weights
that are close enough that these weights
don't drift too much
it requires proof has been tricky but
you can show they don't drift too much
but then you still have to actually find
these weights that are drifting in some
space that you don't know exactly but
have a crude multiplicative
approximation to
but you can play phrase that problem as
a self-contained game you can play
and then there's still some other things
you have to deal with like how do you
really get the initial vertex can you
get to the center of the weighted log
barrier with the right of
uh properties efficiently can you round
to a vertex
there's a lot of standard tricks oh and
how do you actually compute the initial
weights
and do this thing where you maintain
that your weights are always
multiplicably close to true weights
you do some standard tricks from linear
programming use some good insights from
display in 2008
use the right form of gradient descent
to keep computing the optimal weights
and you put all this together
and you get the result the squared
iteration algorithm that only solves a
polylog
number of linear systems per iteration
um
so i have a few slides on just a little
bit of intuition for max flow
and what the actual running times are
but this is the picture for like the
general
interior point scheme any questions on
this before i go further
how much time do i have like five
minutes five ten minutes
yeah okay all right yeah maybe uh
like maybe 10 minutes because we started
three minutes late all right
well see what questions i get asked all
right so let's go all the way back to
the beginning and our motivation for
this model
uh let's look at the maximum flow
problem
so again this is our problem we want to
minimize this linear cost function over
the space of circulation
subject to some capacity constraints or
more generally what we want to do is
solve a linear program
given by n linear inequality constraints
with m linear inequality constraints on
both sides
and again the problem is there really
could be m tight constraints
neither this problem nor its dual is
n-dimensional
so we would want to get a squared and
iteration algorithm but there's no
self-concordant barrier to do this so
what are we going to do
so first i want to say like why you
might hope that these barriers
aren't really barriers at all this is
sort of fuzzy intuition
but first the picture you might have is
that well the local geometry is not that
different
in all of these algorithms when you're
when you run into your points on any of
this typically you're symmetrizing your
domain as you go anyway
like all of these barriers are typically
once you have your central point
you're looking at some ellipse that's
symmetric around that point
so you would hope in some sense you're
never really like looking at both
constraints at the same time they're
never
both completely perturbing your geometry
that much
so you would hope that like locally it
still only looks like you're dealing
with one side
and if this was one-sided then the dual
is undimensional we knew how to solve
that problem
so you can argue that while this is
really an issue for the standard
analysis of self-concordant barriers
maybe it really isn't a problem for
getting this convergence right
the other thing you might think is that
really what our algorithm is showing is
if you have a bunch of simple
constraints
and they're of some form and they sort
of don't interact a certain way that
there's a sense you're not really
sparsifying the constraints but you're
like you're sparsifying the effect of
those constraints
you can always find a re-weighting of
these constraints they don't really
contribute too much force or perturb you
too much
so you could hope that we could still
have barriers one self-concordant
barriers for every one of these
two-sided
domain two-sided constraints on the x-i
and find the right way to modify them so
it's still it always looks like you're
in some
dimensional space but this is just fuzzy
intuition so what we actually do is
first we work out a dual algorithm to
the algorithm we had
a bunch of the degeneracy switch some of
these things that were hard to show
stability of before
like how much the weights can shift
becomes much easier
other things like how much whether you
can
how bounding the size of your ellipse
and l infinity gets a bit trickier
but to deal with that we just showed
that you can really keep track of l
infinity changes explicitly
note a special case of this i'm solving
where a is the empty set
like a is just nothing so in some sense
any algorithm we give needs to
understand that you can minimize over an
unconstrained box
in like constant time so our analysis
more or less
explicitly keeps track of this thing we
keep really explicitly keeps track of
our certain steps of what they do in l
infinity norm
and finally we just we do we actually
treat every one of these barriers
abstractly
for this we were motivated by there was
some previous work on showing how
you can get certain good barriers for
two-sided intervals
um and how that in certain cases you can
make them not
or just you can make nice interior point
methods that deal with them directly
fortunately unfortunately we couldn't at
the time show we could use any of those
barriers so we made some new barrier we
called the trigonometric barrier
it's like log cosine which was kind of
funny um
so you put all those together and you
get you can get it all to work out
so you get a squared iteration algorithm
for this problem in the end it gives you
a number of edges square number of
vertices
algorithm for maximum flow and minimum
cost flow
um all right just three more slides uh
or maybe a little more than that so
first okay so now i've said all this
what is the running time for solving a
general linear program i've somehow
not had to say that anywhere and i
wanted to restrict to this linear system
solving oracle
because i feel like as the maximum flow
problem shows your running time you
should really
often think about the structure of your
problem for how you want to implement
these iterations
but let's just say all we know is the
number of non-zero and for fun
let's say and because i do think the
running times matter a little bit more
than i may be leading on
um let's see what the running times are
if all i know is
m n and the number of non-zero entries
in the matrix a
so what did we need to do in every
iteration we just needed to solve some
linear system involving a
um so we just needed this this
for some positive diagonal entries uh
diagonal matrix d
um this was the second order term and
that we had to solve so
solving um doing our newton steps was
just applying the inverse of this to
some vector
but if i just had some matrix h that was
close to this vector too close to this
matrix
well then i could inverse this matrix
and this is just a d by d matrix
n by n matrix so i could invert this and
end the omega time so as long as i had
some sort of i could efficiently get
some
more compact representation this matrix
would be done but fortunately we can use
these inputs parts to time algorithms we
could use them to solve this directly we
can also use them to form this
approximation to this matrix
so once you have that then your
iteration complexities just end to the
mega so putting the whole thing together
even in renegar's result you could just
get an n z of a plus n to the mega
square root n
iteration algorithm in our algorithm you
can do the same thing so you get nz of a
plus n to the mega
square root n um
one of the other fun things you can do
with the running time and my
understanding
is this has been around even since karma
cars first papers on interior point
methods
is that you can note that in every
iteration of these interior points
schemes
your slacks don't change too much on
average your distance to all the
constraints
if i look their change is
multiplicatively bounded in l2
what i mean by this is suppose you take
an iteration of an interior point scheme
and your distance to one of the
constraint doubles or halves
then yeah it has i guess one of the
distance one that constraint has
and basically all the other constraints
your distances won't change at all
and so using the so this means is on
average
the changes to the linear systems you're
solving are low rank
so you so there's a whole bunch of
tricks you can do
for maintaining an approximate inverse
and using it as a preconditioner for the
true inverse by noting how they're low
rank on average
and this was taken to i think as one
extreme by vaidya in 89
where he showed so if you do renegar's
algorithm you need square root n
iterations
and if you had a dense matrix well in
the worst case you have to apply that
matrix
to a vector so in the worst case your
matrix your cost of every one of your
iterations will be mn
you'll need square root of iterations
and he showed if you can use all this
machinery you can actually make that
the total cost of your algorithm in the
worst case so you can make it that the
average cost of linear systems
is no more than the cost of applying
your matrix a in the case that is dense
uh unfortunately on our our algorithm we
wanted to show that it was at least this
was more just a proof of concept i think
we've gotten the running time
we're working on getting the running
time a lot smaller than that now i can
talk offline um but
we wanted a proof of concept that it was
at least amenable to the same sort
sort of tricks but if you actually take
our algorithm the multiplicative changes
in the slacks are larger on
average like our multiplicative change
of the slacks are bounded in a different
norm
so it really could be like when if
you're if you're picking weights to
diminish the contribution of a bunch of
constraints those constraints like more
constraints can then
step change if you go in that direction
but we should you can still do similar
sorts of tricks
and you can get something that's at
least better in some regimes
really the thing we have is some term
that's about this long of like picking
two or three parameters there's like a
few
knobs you can turn
so there's a real running time as as we
have it in that paper is there's a bunch
of knobs you can turn
and really the best running time is by
turning all those knobs this was i think
inside correct me if it's something else
it's it's from tuning those knobs to
just get something that's strictly
better than this
could you possibly get mn to the 1.5 or
not
um so
we have something in the works well
we'll see that i shouldn't i don't want
to claim at the moment we have to talk
to you
more about it offline um yeah any other
questions so i think the answer is yes
i strongly think the answer is yes
um um all right so
uh just quick some open questions for
future work first is squared nl the end
of the story even if we strict in this
oracle model and ask how many linear
systems we need to solve
madrid's paper is some exciting evidence
that maybe we can do better on that x
maybe we can do better than that half we
can also ask can we get better into your
point message if we use more structure
maybe
counting how many linear systems we
solve is not the best oracle model for
trying to get fast running times for
linear programs
maybe there's substructure we can use
our new combinatorial primitives we can
build in certain regimes
so this list should be longer now
apologies this is some of the results on
maximum flow but using
reiki's countries or richard's idea for
um
getting better recursions out of those
algorithms um
or using any of the primitives developed
by sherman or
or um calendar lorenzo uh inside and
myself
maybe these structures that we're using
to get really fast on directed
algorithms we could use
in some sort of interior points scheme
to get faster convergence rate
or at least if not this some other sort
of structure and last
just a fun one i mean if you could bring
the iteration cost even
down just a little bit further since
we're actually converging at square down
iterations maybe you could hope to get
something like input sparsity time for
linear programming
this would require some notion of
sublinear time per iteration
but um who knows things are changing by
not too much on average if you do it
right
anyway that's that uh thank you very
much
any more questions
did you draw the animation on the last
slide by hand or write a computer
program you and ted programmed it
what algorithm is this actually running
okay no no what algorithm yeah it is
cool yeah so it's ian's hat's handy work
that's the algorithm in action i guess
all right is that the john ellipsoid or
something
yeah yeah approximate john the lips i
think
yeah so thanks